it wouldn't be Valentine's Day without a
string of romance movies it just
wouldn't be the valve stars Channing
Tatum and Rachel McAdams it's a story
that starts out with this couple they're
in love and they love each other just
the wonderful they hold hands and
everything it's so happy and then a car
crash happens that Rachel McAdams loses
her memory and has no idea Channing
Tatum isn't that's horrible
did I say that too fast so yes a car
crash happens she loses her memory and
Channing Tatum has to basically make his
wife fall in love again because she has
no memory of him hey listen I know I am
not the target demographic for this
movie I know that this movie is not made
for me in fact I was talking to a girl
the other day and I told her I was like
you know I saw this movie called the
value probably really liked it she's
like what's it about
I explained the plot to her and she was
like oh yes of course
indeed yes affirmative I want to see it
so yes this is a movie made for chicks
for chicks everything for chicks and you
know what it's surprisingly not awful I
will say that Channing Tatum has matured
a lot as an actor I started out really
not liking the guy but then I continued
to see him good performances like who's
not that mad that's actually pretty good
don't you know and the valley he was
pretty good I liked him in the movie
this is a romance told from the
perspective of the man and I like that
about this movie because I'm a man and
it was a little easier for me to relate
to the lead because a lot of the movie
is actually him really frustrated as a
girl and you know I can kind of relate
to that a little bit the first 15 or 20
minutes of the movie are so sappy it is
not even explainable in words I was like
if the rest of the movie is like this I
don't know what I'm gonna do
but once the plot got rolling the movie
did pick up and I'll tell you why I have
a little bit respect for this film this
film did not fall into all of the common
romance cliches so yes there were quite
a bit of cliches in this movie side
characters completely unnecessary the
evil parents that don't like Channing
Tatum the old boyfriend who suddenly
back in her life but one of the things
this movie did was it really sidetracked
the whole pop song over the images of
characters looking at the
no being sad I call off the montage of
sadness it's a song as put in a movie
after some horrible event happens with
two characters who are in love and
they're all just looking out windows or
riding the bus like looking into the
street or walking with some sad song and
it's supposed to make you feel that way
in this movie they never really had that
they actually let the characters speak
what was on their minds which was
refreshing Rachel McAdams got on my
nerves a little bit I felt like she over
acted a little bit the thing that I
think helped me was that the film was
told from the perspective of a man and
so it was a little easier for me to
relate to it's not an awful movie it's
not a great movie it is surprisingly
okay though which I was really shocked
by actually because I was expecting it
to be awful I'm gonna give the vow of
b-minus I know I know I'm not crazy it
actually is not that bad please believe
me I'd like to know what is your
favorite romance film - 500 days of
summer if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get steppen
eyes